vous avez une expertise qui est aussi
une passion comment vous vous êtes
retrouvé à faire a formé une chaîne
humaine pour sauver des oeuvres qui
étaient dans la cathédrale alors tout
simplement j'ai eu un petit texto de ma
fille qui me dit papa tu as vu notre la
bête en feu oui je les ai vus il était
23 heures quand elle m'a communiqué ce
petit texto
j'étais mon épouse étant au canada j'ai
sauté sur l'occasion en disant oui on y
va et on y va tous les deux et ayant un
chantier j'ai un chantier à notre dame
de paris sur le contrefort donc on avait
les autorisations pour voir rentrer et
cette chaîne humaine a été constitué
d'architecte en chef des monuments
historiques
la compagnie des architectes en chef et
pour tout simplement d'une manière
naturelle et pour une fois j'ai été ce
que j'appelle la petite main c'est pas
moi qui était le chef d'orchestre gtel
le 15e violon de cette chaîne et qu'ils
étaient
dans le calme dans le respect avec le
avec tout ce qui doit être fait pour
sauver le maximum de 2
deux pièces voilà vous dites dans le
calme
moi j'imagine il y avait aussi de la
panique on voulait sortir les choses
alors il ya une règle c'est comme dans
tout vous pourrez voir ne jamais
paniquer c'est à dire que toute
situation quand vous commencez à
paniquer vous faites plus de bêtises et
vous fait plus d'erreurs donc ça nous
sommes formés intellectuellement à ne
jamais paniquer si vous commencez à
paniquer s'est terminée hier nous avons
fait une opération de sauvegarde
importante sur le pignon nord qui
manquait de s'écrouler
sa nécessité quatre heures
d'intervention quatre heures de calme
jamais mettre la pression compagnon
retirer ponctuellement toute opération
ça peut durer quatre heures comme ça
peut durer cinq heures mais ne jamais
précipité on est parti sur un avec une
certaine technique
cette technique nous l'avons valley dsk
était hyper important s'est jamais ce la
vitesse vitesse et précipitation et donc
le fameux ce lundi soir
les architectes en chef les légendes du
ministère de la culture de la ville de
paris étaient présents pour donner la
main connaissent les procédures et
courir ne sert à rien emballer une croix
c'est quelque chose qui doit se faire
dans le calme
précisément et être deux pour la porter
pour pas être trois ça c'est important
et ça c était réellement effectivement
va pas besoin de pas besoin de le
chacun sait chacun le fait et c'est ça
la halle avantage on n'a pas pris
n'importe qui pour faire vous garder
quoi comme souvenir de cette nuit le
souvenir c'est c'est le silence
c'est le côté posé des uns et des autres
et puis de l'humidité
c'est à dire qu'on ne savait pas encore
le lundi soir
si une tour allait tomber si les voûtes
allait tomber tout ce qu'on a pu sauver
c'était ce qui était sauvable skis et l
important peut-être que voilà donc ce
qui était ce qu'on a pu transporter ça
sera toujours un point important et ça
c'est ce qui est resté de savoir si
c'est le bougeoir si c'est le calice si
c'est ça ça ne m'a pas affecté
mais c'était de se dit ah peut-être que
c'est une petite pierre à l'édifice
c'est quoi la suite pour vous maintenant
il y en a pour des semaines et des
semaines encore première phase c'est la
désolation c'est ont fait un constat on
je suis j'étais falot mini-série culture
m'a demandé d'intervenir parce que lundi
soir je suis intervenue à titre bénévole
et à titre parce que j'avais les tripes
de ça c'est important
bardy jour soit effectivement à côté des
fon justement du ministère de la culture
nous demandons d'envoyer éventuellement
sous les instructions de l'architecte en
chef
villeneuve filles et villeneuve des
compagnons pour pouvoir sécuriser la
aujourd'hui l'objet c'est de sécuriser
on a sensiblement une quinzaine de jours
pour sécuriser les les différentes zones
on ne s'était engagé ce soir à sécuriser
et à sécuriser le pignon nord
ça sera fait ça sera pas fait à 8 heures
ce soir ça sera sûrement fait donc
courant de la nuit jusqu'à 1h 2h ou 3h
du matin je vous cache pas qu'on est sur
le pont qu'on dort très peu
on change nos hommes mais les têtes
pensantes sont là et j'en fais partie
cache pas que j'espère que dimanche
dimanche de pâques mais on posera
peut-être nos valises et c'est à dormir
un peu voilà c'est un des points puisque
là il faut réellement sécurisé et là on
a on va avoir ce soir sécuriser le
pignon nord demain matin on attaque le
pignon qui donne sur entre les deux
tours là on a deux jours encore de
sécurisation et la recherche elle va
nous donner ensuite les ordres de
priorité mais déjà si on arrive à
sécurité ces éléments là puisque on est
sur les pignons qu'il n'y a plus de
couverture c'est comme une voile de
bateau
s'il ya le moindre vent on va on va
passer à la chance que nous avons c'est
que d'un tram c'est un feu de
quand gilles lachance s'est jamais de
chance mais la chance c'est un feu de
couverture c'est à dire que notre gamme
en dessous
les vitraux n'ont pas n'ont pas souffert
lors gars c'est lié essentiellement à
l'eau que les pompiers pour refroidir
mais on n'a pas de notre dame n'est pas
noir les vitraux n'ont pas non papeete
c'est resté confiné entre les voûtes et
la couverture donc ça c'est déjà un
point positif il faudra reconstruire les
voûtes
mais les piliers tienne si je peux vous
poser une dernière question vous êtes
allé à l'intérieur c'est comment à
l'intérieur
qu'est ce qu'on voit qu'est ce qu'on
ressent c'est la première fois de ma vie
quand je suis rentré à l'intérieur il ya
matin que j'ai pleuré comme un enfant
l'émotion et j'en ai encore l'émotion
parce que on ne peut pas imaginer que
notre dame de paris
l'emblème puisse être mis à terre mais
elle n'est pas mise à terre il ya eu
simplement un petit souci ça va on va
rebondir mais quand on voit tous sam al
ghad de bois brûlé de doder de
d'éventration de foot c'est quelque
chose qui est cruel
ce que je trouve extraordinaire et je
remercie nos amis canadiens parce que
c'est vrai que j'aime aussi cette nation
c'est tout le monde entier le monde
entier est derrière notre dame de paris
derrière ce point et on va rebondir on
va tous rebondir vous avez dû voir la
photo du coq que l'architecte en chef à
à retrouver c'est vrai que
personnellement c'est moi qui lui ai
fait qu'ils aient fait cette photo parce
que j'étais présent avec l'architecte
c'est lui qui a été chercher au risque
de sa vie
le coq parce qu'il avait considéré qu'il
devait à telle et telle position par
chance il n'a pas pris le feu parce
qu'il était effectivement tombé dans une
dans un chéneau un chéneau c'est une
grande gouttières et il a pu
effectivement être sauvé il l'a pris la
sortie comme un bébé
on va sauver et pour nous les français
le coq c'est l'emblème c'est l'emblème
de la france et on dit toujours dans
notre petit jargon le coq chante quand
il a les pieds dans la merde alors nous
avons les pieds brûlés nous avons les
pieds dans la mer mais on va chanter et
je pense qu'on va renaître de nos
cendres